hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation today I'm
going to give a kind of brief episode
mix things up a little bit rather than
talking about some deep insight into
physics or mathematics that emerges from
equations instead I'm gonna focus upon a
simple issue in math pedagogy math
education I kind of I don't know it kind
of irritates me bothers me I'd be
interested to hear from you all your
perspective if I'm looking at this the
wrong way be happy to have my
perspective change and this is an issue
that I also see cropping up online every
now and then as a simple problem in
arithmetic gets sort of sent around with
people arguing as to what is the right
answer the kind of equation an
arithmetic problem I'm talking about
it's pretty straightforward let me just
pick one at random things like you know
eight say minus two and then we have a
variety of other operations say divided
by two times three plus four so a little
equation like that gets kicked around
and people argue online as to what the
right answer to this problem is and and
there is a real interesting conceptual
issue here which is that the answer
depends on the order of operations so if
I was going to title this little episode
it would be orders order of operations
and that's an interesting subject for
sure so let's just look at it in this
particular example and let me just show
how depending on how you interpret this
equation you will get different answers
let me just copy it down a couple of
times so I can perhaps do it a few times
maybe I can paste it another time here
right so for instance if you interpreted
this to mean that say you did the two
divided by two first in this expression
and you got a 1 there and then if you
did that times the 3 together you get a
3 and then if you had the 8 minus the 3
gives you a 5 plus the 4 would give you
9 that's one answer you get from
interpreting the sentence the
mathematical sentence in that manner
however there are many other things that
you could do for instance if we come
over and let's choose a different color
over here if did the 8 minus 2 first you
get your 6 if you did your 6 divided by
2 that would get you a 3
if you then multiply the 3 by the 3 that
would give you a nine and if you then
added the 4 to that that would give you
13 in this particular case and you know
what other things can you do well I
don't know if say you did the 3 plus the
4 first you got a 7 and then you did the
7 times a 2 you get a 14 over here and
if you did say the 8 minus 2 to get a 6
and then you to 6 divided by the 14 you
have 6 over 14 which would be 3 divided
by 7 so a completely different answer
and again so there is an interesting
conceptual point that this little
example illustrates that the order of
operations in a mathematical sentence
matters to it now here's the part that I
become irritated by so you know my
daughter is in school and in school they
teach her and I don't know maybe they
taught this to me - and I blocked it out
or something from when I was a kid in
school they teach you this thing called
PEMDAS right and PEMDAS is an arbitrary
rule that tells you the order of
operations to employ in any given
mathematical sentence so the P
parentheses exponents m and D
multiplication division and the
addition and subtraction so the idea is
if you're given some sort of
mathematical sentence like this you
employ PEMDAS to figure out which order
of operations to employ and indeed this
top one over here I believe I did in
effect follow the PEMDAS prescription
there weren't any parentheses there
weren't any exponents but I did my
multiplication and my division first and
when you have both multiplication and
division you follow the order of those
operations from left to right as they're
written in the problem so indeed I did
my division first that I did my
multiplication over here and then I did
my addition and subtraction whereas in
these other examples it did something
else fine okay here's the thing
point number one you know I've been in
this business you know being a
professional physicist say you become a
professional when you get your doctorate
okay so I've been a professional for
more than thirty years and I'm pretty
certain that not a single time in my
entire career have I ever made use of
PEMDAS okay and in fact I have to say if
a graduate student
I'd be more forgiving on an
undergraduate student but if a graduate
student came into my office and actually
wrote down on the blackboard this
original mathematical sentence that we
had here from the get-go if I had a
graduate student come into my office and
write down the left-hand side of this I
would say to that student don't talk to
me that way get out of my office right
it probably wouldn't be that mean about
it but I'd say we physicists don't speak
to each other this way we don't speak in
ambiguous mathematical sentences we talk
in precise mathematical sentences and we
don't rely upon some arbitrary acronym
PEMDAS in order to make sense of the
mathematical sentences rewrite down
instead I would say to that graduate
student are you kidding me
where are your parentheses we use
parentheses to indicate precisely the
order of operations that we have in mind
so in fact if the interpretation of this
mathematical sentence was meant to be
the one that comes out of PEMDAS I would
want my student and what we
professionals always do to write down
some parentheses so I would do say a
parentheses like this and then I would
do another one say over here and that
would tell me to do the 2/2 first to get
my 1 then do my 1 times my 3 to get 3
and then do my 8 minus 3 is 5 plus 4
equals 9 that's it we simply use
parentheses to make it very precise and
clear what it is that we mean with our
mathematical sentences and indeed if the
second interpretation is the 1 say that
the graduate student had in mind the
graduate student would simply write 8
minus 2 with some nice parentheses
around it and then if the dividing by 2
was meant to happen next they could put
another parenthesis and to make it more
clear they could put say a square
bracket around it and then if we wanted
to be even more precise we could say the
times 3 is next with those parentheses
and then we would add our 4 so we get
our 8 minus 2 / 6 divided by 2 is 3
times 3 is 9 plus 4 is equal to 13 and
that's it no PEMDAS necessary we just
make certain that our mathematical
sentences are clear by using parentheses
to bracket those operations that we want
to happen first or second or third and
so forth so what's my what's my gripe
here my gripe is the following when my
daughter learned this PEMDAS order of
operations thing in school they spent
and maybe I'm exaggerating but they
spent weeks on it and they kept giving
my daughter problem enough to prob
after problem all sorts of ambiguous
looking arithmetic aproblem x' and was
up to her to apply this PEMDAS rule to
figure out what the answer to a given
problem was meant to be and all these
problems there gotcha problems there
they're meant to try to trip her up and
at the end of this long exercise that
went on at least four days and maybe
weeks and I think was if in in two
different years in school they've
repeated it at the end of this process
what did my daughter take away she took
away the notion that math is all about
applying arbitrary rules to make sense
of a collection of arbitrary symbols and
it was kind of for me so so kind of
heartbreaking so it felt like so I felt
so dejected by it because that's not
what math is right math is not about
these arbitrary rules math is about the
wondrous patterns that we can
encapsulate with the precise
mathematical sentences that we write
down so if it was up to me what would I
do I would advocate look give the
students a couple examples like the
example I just gave you show them this
absolutely important concept that the
order of operations does matter but with
a couple examples kids will get that and
then tell them show them that by using
parentheses you can make clear the order
of operations that you have in mind when
you write down a mathematical sentence
period end of story
and from that point forward you can move
on to the beautiful qualities of math
that can articulate the patterns of the
world so the point is at any opportunity
we should take away the quality of math
that you apply rules you do apply rules
but we should take away that quality we
should not emphasize that quality when
there's an opportunity to emphasize the
beauty of math the power of math to
encapsulate wondrous and universal
patterns we should
focus in that direction and here's a
case where you'd never need to introduce
PEMDAS just introduce the concept of the
ambiguity of the order operations and
then this idea of using brackets or
parentheses to make sense precise
mathematical sense of every single
mathematical sentence you write down and
that's what we professionals do we don't
use PEMDAS anyway so that's that's my
point I'd be interested to hear from you
guys if you have a different view on
this deep do you make use of PEMDAS in
in the work that you do or and the
analysis that you undertake I thinks
computer programmers may have a slightly
different perspective as you can make
your code perhaps a little tighter if
you make use of these sort of arbitrary
rules but it I be interested in here
that perspective directly as well but
that's that's the episode for today math
is about patterns beautiful Universal
patterns that we can encapsulate with
the precise mathematical sentences and
that's where the beauty and wonder comes
from not from applying arbitrary rules
over and over and over again that's not
math that's drudgery anyway that is the
point for today that is your daily
equation really I would like to hear
from you if you have a different
perspective on this but until next time
until the next episode take care